digo é que eu vou sair o meu cu 1
o lado pessoal de quem fala ai então bn
a hoje vamos jogar um jogo de terror e
vocês terão duas grelhas né hoje
pessoalmente buscar um jogo bem pior
jogo que vai ajustar os frutos do
cortejo procurados por resgatar e deixei
lá eo pessoal da chela e que está aqui
vai ser branco é que ela abrange seu
filho foi selecionado para participar
gratuitamente um novo acampamento de
verão organizado por essa escola cuidado
e atenção se o filho para ser um verão
inesquecível porque eu escuto de tudo o
que faz tem cuidado eu não podia mexer
no jogo eu e na porta de um carro
[Música]
o a fugir não o que eu não sou bom pra
isso eu não gostaria de enviar
notificação não não não é isso também
vale no tablado né
acho que fui dar uma olhada antes de
andar pra frente você é burro agora vou
lançar um pouco aí está em ensinar
design frame
neste caso os jogos do roma é talvez eu
preciso da chave
acharia que e isso muito bem feito
questiona a decisão possa deixar agora
precisa ser necessário mover se para
encontrar uma saída está aí alguém vai
ai ouviu qualquer ato de quando aqui já
onde aquino maria da costa à câmara será
sem querer encontrar qualquer coisa que
pode ter é anos que é um livro mas
nenhum conseguiu ganhar em tudo que
neste o papel eo a um só mas se você já
não estão a servir
de resgate comenta e o que quer fazer
uso de um code dias que joguei no futuro
[Música]
ou será que é uma tristeza como é cuidar
que susta sinto alto é um jogo bem
público está quitado 10 milhões a
qualquer som que eu estou aqui me
assustou muito
alguém tem um som também foi um fundo
criado em bom ver só o tempo dirá que
deixa a escola esse é o objetivo e isso
foi muito bom do jogo não pode dizer que
ela vai pegar aqui já que isso é
importante não é uma porta é não é isso
aí mantê-la acho ótimo precisa a rua
meus amigos e encontre sairé eu estou na
rua eu vou escapar de sofrer era tirar a
carteira menina estava fechando que tem
um trunfo é bom eu não se tem que poder
que não fosse lê seu campo base
meu deus quem deu um passo e focado
foi meu deus
continuo é a vida pra saltar aqui no
topo daquela entrou ela vai de outubro
que também dão aqui um pouquinho da
nossa ajuda mais do que nunca precisamos
ajudar a casa mãe dos homens embora fred
não pode entrar aqui é xará mexicano
carlos vela e gene não precisa que eu
chamo não pode ser removido alguma coisa
está segurando fuzis do quartel assim
nem tem outra casa mãe nessa ela por
entrar tem que ter muita visão aqui
é nada que me perguntou tá muito perto
está trancada com uma chave
lula não considera aqui não dá estou
limitado e precisa do martelo preciso de
chaves automáticos estuda aqui eu não
consigo encarar este jogo ok vamos
voltar tudo atrás tudo e traz calma e
gritando pedindo isso ai meu coração eu
vou morrer de um ataque epilético eu sei
que o fred é o que eu consigo usar a
vacina contra a freira não sei mas vamos
tentar agora o meu deus é um eventual do
santo anastácio isto é eu voltar a ver
comigo não quer saber só entre o troço
pão ok pessoal desta vez vou tentar
segurar bem estas só uso a cair vamos
tentar ver se encontramos alguma chavo
qualquer coisa assim e olha que o
organismo
hoje é um hotel para acessar você
precisa estar no capítulo o desafio um
labirinto
existem vários capítulos como esse que o
lucro a todos os quartos que eu não
consigo acessar supostamente dentro do
labirinto tem passagens discretas que
vão dar essas salas para me sentir um
chefe ou o fred no segundo piso
meu deus na escola é muito grande e
nunca nunca
o a final da 1ª feirã ayew em poder bem
fácil
o frei não conseguia esticar o braço a
isso não vai funcionar
rodrigo alvim e will i am
o meu o boca-a-boca otária louca
portanto meu coraçãozinho sedã é que o
buraco no muro ele que não só não solta
não solta mas sei que é um sonho do
ituano onde é isso coisa macabra não não
eu não quero nessa escola não quis um
buraco por buraco do tatu que isto eu
sou professora eu voltar a pessoa só
precisa começar ontem né não eu sou
muito profissional toma cartão com o
número que ninguém irá esconder dos do
be conclui aqui por perto
ai ai ai que gostoso lindo agora tá feio
copiar todas engraçado eu não sei é
cabra olha ai isso na história o homem
com um martelo ela vem como hotel salta
da acção tá solta
ae op o edital e não tem nada que cabo
misturar seu livro eu livro o livro não
é não
vamos focar só qualidade sem problema é
sempre bom não faz muito ruído em uma só
causa
ela tá querendo fechar fora isso ok tem
lugar aqui um livro outra vez e colocar
ali no quintal onde o galo e filha do
escroto
se não não estou mal estou mal
são paulo o goleiro não dia 4 você pode
procurar o carro nas gavetas da cozinha
geralmente estávamos lá pra cozinha
agora lá da cozinha em cima e isso é que
toca agora é só encontrar 500 metros é
sério e eu não vi uma decisão sobre isso
eu sou muito nisso ok vai embora fred
vai embora mas vocês formaram 16 pela
esquerda vemos a voltar mesmo fugimos
voltam se esconder e depois voltamos
aqui sim eu vou tentar fazer história em
3d em 2001 o checão mulheres ou chegam
mensal maior foco as quais a ele agora
só com essa causa é esse mesmo de férias
o indicador é é agora ela está lá em
cima é preciso esconder aqui e espero
que ela saia de cima da hora pra isso
olha que escalará andré é de trânsito
para o professor com suco presidente
tinha gente porque isto é preciso cabo
provei que já percebi que eu tenho uma
pista é tão louco e vt da gaveta em
gaveta ea chave amarela febre amarela
poxa meu deus eu não agüentei essa opção
é muita coisa atrás de mim meu ela vai
com um martelo dólares como eu talvez
sério o pior podem fazer jogos flor é
perseguição no olho não é você estar ou
energia elétrica que estava faltando
muito bem ok mas agora vamos buscar
achava eu preciso chegar a algum lugar
não sei onde você quer você que terão
que isso nunca teve 13 da webb ainda não
faz mais isso
a freira não faz mais isso muito em um
dia qualquer pessoa a última
oportunidade para escapar da escola
[Aplausos]
hélio e gosto de ser escalado
você ainda está na hora de sair da
escola pode continuar mais um dia se
assistir um vídeo produzido na nenê
qualquer só vamos ficar por aqui com
espírito e uma vez aí eu disse que este
lugar é pior do que o rei e eu disse já
não só o baixinho vosso life como em
portimão com os nossos amigos e é isso
fique bem e até a próxima